[Music]
community school of the year
sponsored by Stover golf club burns
primary school burns is a small school
nestled in the center of Newton Abbot
last year burns set a whole school Drive
to race participation in physical
activity the result has been phenomenal
with children enjoying new equipment and
facilities this year Burns is taken part
in a number of different events and
tournaments and they ever even organized
their own sports week and given older
students the chance to be role models
for younger students as play leaders
this effort has transformed a sedentary
school within an area of high social
deprivation to a much more energized
motivated and enthused school community
decoyed primary school decoyed primary
school has 420 children as a school they
actively promote sport both
competitively and socially decoy offer a
variety of clubs including football
netball handball and many more decoy
students have attended many festivals
and competitions hosted by the south
Dartmoor partnership their success has
been driven by the dedication of the PE
staff and the determination of the
children to succeed or even have a go
achievements are highlighted by children
who attended decoy primary school going
on to represent their county and their
country in some sports
[Music]